one time I barfed up macaroni and cheese
and you know it's funny it's how I
actually met my ex-boyfriend we went to
go see this Garage Band in like this
cool Underground club and I was in there
like bopping my head and all of a sudden
I was like oh dear it's that moment so I
ran out into the back alley and this guy
came out and he was like sorry I just
didn't want you to be alone out here
it's a little dangerous and I was
like and then I just hear is that mac
and cheese
and that is how I met my ex-boyfriend
really yeah we were together for two
years and he is the most wonderful human
the kindest most gentle he's 6'4 blonde
tall just the best but that's how we bet
wow it all started with vomit in a back
alley you never know where love can be
found yeah that's a beautiful story
isn't it